et c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus
à la une ce soir alpha condé poursuivis
pour assassinat la justice guinéenne
ouvre une procédure contre l'ex
président renversé l'an dernier une
trentaine d'autres personnalités sont
également visées toutes sont mises en
cause dans la répression meurtrière du
mouvement de contestation fin 2019 qui
avaient fait des dizaines de morts
et si le charbon du sud africain
remplaçait celui de la russie alors que
les européens ont imposé un embargo sur
le charbon russe suite à l'invasion de
l'ukraine bruxelles courtisent l'afrique
du sud qui dispose d'importantes
réserves le pays s'est pourtant engagé à
réduire sa production de charbon une
ressource fortement polluantes
et il sera justement question de
réchauffement climatique et de
transition écologique dans le journal de
l'afrique la conférence sur la
désertification et la sécheresse s'ouvre
lundi en côte d'ivoire jean-luc assis
ministre ivoirien de l'environnement et
du développement durable et m'ont invité
l'annoncé a été faite par le procureur
général de conakry alpha condé ainsi que
26 autres hauts responsables sont
poursuivis notamment pour assassinat
actes de torture et enlèvements sur la
liste communiquée à la presse figurent
d'anciens ministres députés mais aussi
l'ancien président de la cour
constitutionnelle
ces poursuites sont lancées à la suite
d'une plante du fn des c'est le
collectif qui a mené pendant des mois à
partir d'octobre 2010 9 la contestation
contre un troisième mandat d'alpha condé
les précisions à conakry de notre
correspondant malik diakité
ils sont tous poursuivis pour des faits
présumés de l'assassinât et complicité
de meurtres disparitions forcées
enlèvement ou encore pour des agressions
sexuelles
parmi les personnalités concernées par
cette annonce du procureur général
alphonse alouettes alpha condé le
président dessus un ancien président de
la cour constitutionnelle
d'anciens présidents de l'assemblée
nationale
un ancien premier ministre et plusieurs
anciens ministres députés et
responsables des services de sécurité le
15 avril les avocats du front national
pour la défense de la constitution avait
déposée auprès du procureur général près
la cour d'appel de conakry un lot de
preuves de crimes et exactions qui
auraient été commis entre 2019 et 2020
pendant ses années de pouvoir alpha
condé est accusée d'autoritarisme pas
plusieurs ong de défense des droits de
l'homme la vive contestation contre son
troisième mandat largement repris mais
avait fait des dizaines de morts
les suit celle du bras de fer entre
paris et bamako les militaires au
pouvoir au mali ont déclaré que la force
anti djihadistes française barkan
n'avait plus de base légale pour opérer
dans le pays annonce qui intervient
après la dénonciation par bamako al ans
d'histoire des accords de coopération
militaire l'union européenne juge
regrettable la décision du mali de
dénoncer les accords de défense avec la
france et de son côté l'allemagne a
annoncé mettre fin à sa mission de
formation de l'armée somalienne
l'insécurité est l'une des répercussions
d akkad des attaques djihadistes au
burkina faso le phénomène prend de
l'ampleur les violences poussent à
l'exode les habitants des territoires
ruraux qui se retrouvent sans ressource
et ils n'ont eu d'autre choix que de
laisser derrière eux bien souvent leurs
récoltes et leurs troupeaux provoquant
une hausse des prix de l'alimentation le
récit de laurent berthet 'cher
contraintes de fuir son village martin
roamba n'a pas mangé à sa faim depuis
des mois la jeune femme qui vit
aujourd'hui dans un camp de déplacés
n'arrive même plus à l'été sa petite
fille
les djihadistes sont venus dans notre
village et ils ont tout détruit nous
avons fui vers ouagadougou mais la vie
est difficile avant on mangeait ce qu'on
cultive et mais ici c'est impossible il
faut tout acheter et les prix augmentent
le cas de martin est loin d'être isolé
les violences 10 à 10 ton poussé près de
deux millions de burkinabè à fuir les
campagnes pour les villes laissant
derrière eux leurs récoltes et leurs
bétails l'exode rural a également
provoqué une flambée des prix qui ont
presque doublé en un an les
organisations humanitaires tirent
désormais la sonnette d'alarmé si rien
n'est fait pour endiguer les violences
près de 630 mille personnes pourraient
être menacées par la famine au niveau
sécurité à cette situation haussier et
un train de se dégrader de plus en plus
on a de plus en plus de formations
sanitaires qui se ferme les populations
ont de plus en plus besoin d'être aidé
nous avons plus de deux millions et demi
de personnes qui ont besoin d'une
assistance alimentaire
la situation pourrait encore empirer
pour les programmes dead qui manque déjà
cruellement de fonds plusieurs bailleurs
ont récemment annoncé une baisse de
leurs financements pour le burkina faso
à cause de la guerre en ukraine
et la guerre en ukraine est justement
une opportunité pour les producteurs de
charbon sud africain certains ne
traitaient qu'avec l'europe il ya dix
ans avant que la russie ne s'impose
pretoria envisage de récupérer ses parts
de marché d'autant que les stocks ne
manquent pas voyez ce reportage de nos
correspondants caroline dumay stéphane
carstens et nadine terme
dans le quartier d'affaires de sandton à
johannesburg la guerre en ukraine ne
fait pas que des malheureux cet homme
d'affaires vend des sons charbon aux
pays asiatiques
il est aujourd'hui très courtisé par les
sociétés européennes
les gros fournisseurs qui peuvent
remplacer le charbon russe c'est
l'afrique du sud et la colombie
nous avons eu énormément de demandes de
la part des européens et on a commencé à
le renvoyer à notre chambre on a tout ce
qu'il faut ici en fait là de la main
d'oeuvre qualifiée d infrastructures on
sait travailler dans une mine la seule
chose c'est de pouvoir rêver que la
marchandise vers les ports maritimes
sa société dispose de plus d'un million
de tonnes de stock d'anthracite
industriels son plus gros problème est
aujourd'hui d'acheminer cette
marchandise les voies ferrées sud
africaines sont endommagés il faut des
camions pour arriver jusqu'au port afin
de pouvoir envoyer le charbon par bateau
cela coûte beaucoup plus cher que prévu
mais qu'importe car les prix ont explosé
avec la crise ils sont passés de 100 à
plus de 300 euros la tonne de charbon
pour cet analyste c'est parce que les
profits sont énormes que les
exportations explose bielher
si on regarde l'an dernier à la même
époque on a une augmentation de 900 %
des exportations vers l'europe
ce qui veut dire qu'on a exporté en
avril 2022 ils fois plus qu'en avril
mais ce sursaut d'exportation arrive à
un moment bien singulier le gouvernement
sud africain a promis de réduire sa
production de charbon l'europe lui a
même offert l'an dernier plus de 8
milliards d'euros pour l'aider dans sa
transition énergétique
si les exportations de charbon sont si
rentable il sera bien difficile de
respecter les engagements pris à glasgow
en novembre 2000 21 lors de la cop 26
et c'est une autre coop qui s'ouvre
lundi à abidjan la cop15 la conférence
sur la désertification et la sécheresse
deux enjeux majeurs pour le continent
qui voit ses terres s'appauvrir et ses
ressources comme l'eau se raréfier à
abidjan 5000 participants 2 196 pays
sont attendus et ils seront reçus
notamment par le ministre ivoirien de
l'environnement et du développement
durable jean luc assise qui est aussi
mon invité monsieur le ministre bonsoir
bonsoir madame alors on va tout de suite
entré dans le vif du sujet l'urgence
climatique est là elle n'est plus à
prouver des promesses ont été faites
lors des dernières conférences sur le
climat et comme on vient de voir dans ce
reportage sur l'afrique du sud le pays a
promis de limiter sa production charbon
elle a même reçu des fonds impôts cela
mais elle s'apprête à ne pas tenir ses
objectifs car des opportunités
économiques se sont présentés à la alors
comment croire en l'engagement des pays
merci des bonnets cette occasion donc
pour pour éclairer les uns des autres
sur la coop qui est le sujet principal
sur lequel donc nous allons débattre
mais comme vous parlez des du climat
effectivement à la coop à l'accord de
paris il avait des engagements qui ont
été pris
évidemment au niveau de la coque à
glasgow les annales ces engagements ont
été ont été renforcées
mais il faut dire que tous ces
engagements étaient contenus dans des
documents
sous forme donc des mesures et ces
mesures sont son été on était donc a
publié par les différents pays au niveau
de la côte d'ivoire un certain nombre
des mesures dont qui sont contenus dans
les contributions déterminées au niveau
national qui devrait permettre qu'ils
doivent permettre une logiquement donc
de réduire donc les effets des gaz à
effet de serre
les ambitions donc l'ambition de la côte
d'ivoire a été porté donc à 32 4% à 4 4%
des
réductions donc des gaz à effet de serre
c'est vrai que les pays ont pris des
engagements mais il faut il faut il faut
noter il faut noter avec beaucoup de
regrets que ces pays les pays donc non
pas tenir les engagements et c'est ce
qui a été dit donc la conférence des
parties à glasgow monsieur le ministre
la désertification dont il va être
question
à abidjan lundi c'est surtout c'est
désertification l'épuisement des terres
cultivables sous l'effet de l'activité
humaine et des changements climatiques
sa touche 45 % des terres sur le
continent et votre pays la côte d'ivoire
est aussi concernée car le secteur de
l'agriculture représente près du quart
du pib quelles sont les mesures à
prendre sans attendre pour lutter contre
cette dégradation des terres sur le
continent
mais ce qu'on sait qu'il faut noter
c'est que le gouvernement ivoirien donc
à appeler des mesures des mesures pour
dans le cadre de la résolution de la
dégradation donc d'été
dès son arrivée au pouvoir l'an de
plaisir la centrale bonnet donnent des
instructions fermes au gouvernement pour
réaliser un diagnostic exhaustif donc la
situation et pour inverser bien sûr la
tendance a tenu donc les conséquences
désastreuses pour l'économie ivoirienne
et pour les populations sans oublier la
conservation de la biodiversité et des
services écosystémiques
alors une série donc d'actions ont été
prises à savoir donc
prendre fermement donc position en
faveur du concept cacao zéro
déforestation
par une implication active donc d'une
initiative un partenariat public privé
qui a permet donc de financer donc le
programme initiative cacao forêt il y à
un certain nombre des mesures notamment
donc la facilitation de la mise en
oeuvre de la nouvelle politique
forestière qui s'appuie sur un nouveau
contre les styles et les prenez aussi la
gestion durable des terres
donc voilà c'est un homme des mesures
dont quinté prise pour pour atténuer
atténuer donc là la patte d'éph
activités pour la pub des facilités des
terres et est ce que ces mesures
s'inscrivent dans le abidjan legacy
programme ce programme de restauration
des terres que vous allez présenter
justement lors de la confiance
à oui biensur vous savez le legacy
programme est un programme donc va être
porté par le chef de l'état et qui est
qui qui va adresser donc toutes les
questions toutes les questions donc lié
donc à l'environnement notamment donc la
foresterie
aussi tout ce qui est donc
techniques qui permettent donc des dates
de réduire de réduire donc la perte des
festivités des sols et aussi la
restauration de la restauration donc des
sceaux donc
c'est vrai que nous avons une
pluviométrie donc en côte d'ivoire qui
est très dense mais il faut dire qu'avec
la déforestation avancé nous sommes
confrontés donc à une à une dégradation
excessive des des notaires et ce qui a
un impact véritable sur la production
agricole
jean-luc asémiste y voyant de
l'environnement et du développement
durable qui va notamment accueillir
cette cop 15 à abidjan voilà c'est la
fin du journal de l'afrique je vous
retrouve dans moins d'une heure pour une
nouvelle édition à tout à l'heure
[Musique]